Hôm qua sau Trung Quốc ngày 20-20, theo thời thần với Mỹ,
chúng ta cần đình sẽ gặp tổng thống Mỹ đơn nân trăm,
tại thành phố Bú San Hàn Quốc và ngày 30-20,
người phân muốn bộ qua sau Trung Quốc quách gia con trở biết,
bắt kênh sánh sản hợp tác, để bởi đàn của gặp đặt kích quả tích cửa,
góc phần định hướng phát triển nụ định quanh hiện sống phương.
Cuộc gặp cũng được xem là cơ hội để hai bên chào đổi,
về các bản địa thành chấu Trung quanh hiện sống phương,
bà gồm thương mại công nghệ chi và kìm sát triển nền phát tán nhiên.
Tổng thống đơn nân trăm cho biết,
ông muốn thảo lần cụ thể về chi chỉ thuận nhân tạo Blackwell của im vijia,
trong khi bắt tình nhận mạnh,
mục tiêu hướng tới quanh hiện ord để ý và hợp tác,
thì chương trình quan Trung Quốc đã phản nứng tích cửa,
bằng lên mất cao nhất trong mời năm qua,
trước khi vọc của gặp có thể mở ra đi nh hiểu tích cửa chực kinh tế và thương mại tòn cầu.